welcome back to 8701
in this section we want to look at how
we can theoretically
describe masses of neutrinos
there is not just one way to do this and
the judge is still
out there which one is actually realized
in nature
or perhaps both are realized in nature
so mass terms can be constructed
by introducing so-called stereo
neutrinos
the first way in shown here in the
origin is very familiar to you where you
have
a left-handed component of a particle
coupling via
the higgs boson to a right-handed
component
now if we now have a right-handed
component or right-handed
neutrino that neutrino does not interact
with the weak interaction and doesn't
interact with any other interaction we
know
hence this neutrino this right-handed
particle
is a stereo neutrino is not interacting
in any of
known ways um other than with the higgs
field
with with this uh rest of the standard
model
the second part the second way they can
mechanism
is using
marijuana particles particles which are
their own anti-particles and we'll look
in
how this is being implemented so again
the first
the direct term is generated after
electrobic symmetry breaking
from your cava interactions we have seen
the very same thing for our charge
lepton
what we see here is that the lepton
number is conserved
you know before and after the
interaction we have the same
number of leptons but the lepton flavor
is not
conserved in this interaction we can
rewrite this
um we identify the stereo neutrino as a
right-handed component of the spino i
mentioned this already
um and you know we basically couple
the the weak duplet components as you
would just expect
that that to appear
the second term the majorana mass term
is interesting as we introduce another
singlet into the standard model
so this then can appear as a bear mass
term
with some consequences so here what we
are trying to do is we
involved two neutrinos right-handed
fields
um those breaks electron number
so if those neutrinos are realized in
nature
we have to observe lepton we should
observe lepton number violating
processes
and so the search for the specific kind
of neutrino is through
searching for lepton while laptop number
violating processes
so we can rewrite this part of the
lagrangian this part of the mass term
here using this matrix so let's see how
this unfolds
if the mass term now is um
much much larger or more larger than
the uh electroweak scale um you can try
to
diagonalize the master and it leads to
three neutrinos three light neutrinos
three
neutrinos you would expect and one
potentially
one potential or maybe multiple
potential heavy nurturing
if you then rewrite the mass term you
find for the light ones
the term which goes is one over
the scale of this neutrino that
is a nice motivation for this kind of
physics as it
automatically reduces the mass of the
neutrino as we
observe their masses to be very small in
nature
and then the mass of the heavy neutrino
is proportional to the mass
this mechanism is called seesaw because
you automatically
move the scales of those two of those
two neutrinos
the heavy ones and the light one apart
so you know you haven't observed the
heavy one maybe because they're very
very heavy
and the light ones have light mass
because of this mechanism
of being proportional to one over the
mass scale
uh the mass eigenstate of those matrix
however if the mass scale of those
eigenvalues is
much not
higher than the electrophilic scale the
lower energy
spectrum contains this additional light
states so you have
not just the three light neutrinos but
you have additional
light scales states which mix
with these three light neutrinos and
that is kind of an interesting um
area of to look for these particles as
they would lead to
small deviations in observed electroweak
position properties
um and they might probably yield to some
interesting
decays in nuclear physics and we'll come
to those specifics
later so we have seen in this lecture
two different ways to generate masses
one is to
recover interactions same as you know
the
interaction with the higgs field and one
via the seesaw mechanism
introducing majorana knowledge